so everybody loves the office so much
this people
it means so many things
so many people i've heard you know
stories of
people were sick and they felt better
because they watched the office or or
you know
it's the only thing their family bonds
over you know when the one time week
they come together and now people are
like
you know this is my fourth time seeing
it through the ninth cycle or all of
that uh so it's it's been amazing it's
amazing right it's like
and being a part of the office is
it's like having friends everywhere you
go
you know somebody's going to know it
and you have somebody talk to have a
deal with where do you think that some
of the characters would be in the office
today if you projected in your fantasies
where would your friends be well uh uh
daryl will probably be somewhere on a
private jet with some
i'm in
i want to be on a private jet
yes please anyone else uh
i think meredith is uh is
is working with a.a people like like
and uh i don't think anybody can find
creek
he's alive and well but you just can't
find it
well
i think that gives uh
everybody something to chew on and they
want to be
chewing on it
the office does transcend my daughter
and i watch it together she's going to
be 10 and it's one of our favorite shows
um we also just watch um the bad guys
together and
craig you're in it
you're the shark it's such a good movie
it's so well done it's really clever
it feels a cut above there's a lot of
intelligence
um i think it's very smart but it's
super fun
what was it like to do it because it
really treads a line it's it's a unique
tone and it's really good it's like
tarantino for kids yes
yes
thank you
that's it
like they knew what they were doing by
casting all of you guys and then they
didn't try to
and then they made that movie it's so
good it's so well done thank you it's uh
it was so much fun to do we did it over
the pandemic
so you know it was it was over zoom and
then uh i'd be in the booth and having a
blast the uh the director and the and
the producer of pierre damon we we we
you know throwing jokes back back and
forth and it was just it was a blast my
character was so much fun because he got
to you know be a master of disguise and
there's
some i hope they put on the extras but i
tried to do a french accent and uh
do you want to give us a sample of that
well i mean
it wasn't
it wasn't
it wasn't good but it made me an actress
i love it i'm meeting with all like the
critics are saying because i am like god
i found this movie so intelligent
riveting and like a unique tone and
they're all saying the same thing so i'm
like oh awesome so stupendous job and
thank you for thank you all of us
parents are sitting on the couch
watching the kids
[Music]